I think one of the real great
lessons and good things that came
out of COVID is, I think
it I think empathy went up.
You know,
a lot of leaders, a lot of people
in leadership positions
when COVID struck, they
picked up the phone and called their
team members one by one and said,
"Are you OK?"
Whether
they were effective or ineffective
leaders prior to COVID, they did
that.
They just defaulted to
being human.
And the irony is that's just
called good leadership.
Like you
should have been doing that.
And I hope you continue to do that.
It's not just in this moment of
time.
And you
talk about the infinite game and
worthy rivals and competitors,
there's not a single company on the
planet.
When COVID struck that was
obsessed with beating their
competition.
Every single one of them was
obsessed with just staying alive.
And by the way, that's an infinite
mindset.
The obsession with staying in the
game and staying alive is this
is the correct mentality in good
times or bad times.
And so the point is is the irony is,
is that those skill
set are many of them are innate.
We just for some, for some reason,
ignore them or suppress them or
think that they're only relevant at
one time and not another.
And
I think that was, you know, when we
all went virtual,
you know, and we saw people
disheveled
and, you know, sometimes leaders,
they put on a brave face all the
time.
They always have all the
answers.
They're always confident,
always happy, always good.
And that actually sometimes
backfires.
I had when I was young in my career,
I had my first time having a direct
report, had one direct report,
Cynthia.
She made me look good every
day and it was my
habit to let her sit
in in more senior meetings just to
learn she would have no role.
I would just invite her to sit in.
Why not, right?
And we had a very senior client
call with me and a couple of
a bunch of the senior folks.
And Cynthia was just sat on the on
the sidelines to listen, and it was
a very frustrating call that did not
go well.
And when we hung up the the when
we hung up the conference call, I
vented, it all
came out negativity
against this client, right?
In front of people who were more
senior than me or peers who I
trusted and some of them were, you
know, mentors.
And so I felt safe doing it.
And then I turn around, I see
Cynthia sitting there, and as
we're walking out of the meeting, I
00:02:19:23 00:02:21:02
go, "Oh, I'm so sorry, you shouldn't
have seen that.
That was totally
unprofessional.
I totally
apologize."
And she said, "No, no,
no.
I'm so glad
you did that because
I have been frustrated with this
client and I've been struggling with
this client.
And you're always happy
and you're always good and you're
always competent.
And I started to believe it was me.
And seeing your frustration made
me feel it's not me."
And so when we saw our leaders
and our on our colleagues disheveled
and tired and
and scared, it
actually made us come together
when we saw their kids
run through the screen or their
puppy get in the way.
All of a sudden, they became human.
They have families.
We knew what their houses look like.
We knew what their design sense look
like.
I hate it when people put
those artificial backgrounds because
I actually want to see your space.
You know, how come you have no art
on any of your walls?
You know, buy that person, some art,
I know what I'm getting you for your
next bonus, you know?
But I thought it made us a lot more
human.
And what I'm really hoping,
I'm hoping, is that some of that
survives.
That we do get to know somebody and
know the names of their kids
and know that they've got a four
year old sitting on their lap.
Like, I thought that was beautiful,
and it made us all more more patient
too.
Like, we didn't care that
they were distracted for a minute,
you know?